[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris mannix always great to talk to one
of the great
nba writers former ball boy with the
boston celtics uh what do you think
about that celtics the favorites this
next season
i think that's fair
at this point um
you know like brogdon
adds the play-making they said they were
looking for
galinari adds
uh a ninth or tenth type of man that can
spell al horford during the regular
season and give you scoring potentially
in the postseason the one concern i have
with boston at this point is
you got a lot of guys that are used to
playing nba minutes and
how does that all work i mean brogden
was a starter during his three years in
indiana he's been a bench player he's
saying all the right things right now
but you get to january and february is
he going to be happy in a supporting
role so
how the minutes shake out and how
everybody accepts those roles will be
interesting but on paper
um
they should be right up there with
golden state as as co-favorites
you were at the summer league so i'm
sure there's a lot of chatter about
kyrie and kevin durant um
is there a pecking order of who gets
traded first between those two
expectation is that the nets won't do a
deal involving kyrie irving until
they've figured out what they're going
to do with kevin durant's
um
you brought this up right before i came
on like will the nets
trade kevin durant or is it possible
he could be back
you look brooklyn has set a pretty high
asking price teams that have been
calling and
as recently as this weekend where
everyone is convened at summer league
that price has not changed it's a couple
of all-star level players it's draft
picks it's
you know bigger than anthony davis
bigger than rudy gobert the biggest
asking price probably in nba history
if they stick with that asking price
there's a pretty good chance durant is
back in training camp with the nets the
only way i think that they
are able to move durant is if they come
down a little bit to maybe one all-star
level player
and draft pick still a big package but
not the kind of haul
that
they would have been hoping for
when they originally started mapping out
a way to do a durant deal so
it's possible i'll tell you what someone
else did i wrote something
today for si.com
about how
there are executives in the league ones
that aren't really involved in the
durant sweepstakes
that are in a way rooting for the nets
to hold on to durant
this this trend of players
that sign contracts and then force their
way out
is growing you had james harden a couple
of years ago with two years left on his
deal say i want out and got traded
ben simmons um four years left on his
deal when he asked out of philadelphia
said i won out eventually got traded you
recently saw bradley beal sign a
five-year extension 250 million dollars
nobody really expects him to be in
washington for the duration of that deal
team executives
they kind of want to curb this a little
bit this trend of players signing
contracts and like you know what it's
not really what i thought it was going
to be
i want to get out of here so the teams
that want durant are still hopeful they
can get him but there are teams out
there that want to see the nets and
anyone else involved in situations like
this draw a line in the sand and say you
signed a contract you're with us you've
got to honor it yeah i wouldn't
accommodate either of these guys when i
hear that he wants to go to phoenix i'd
say
tough bleep you know kyrie wants to go
to lakers tough
you know we're going to do something
good for us
yeah and i addressed this in the story
like there are executives that want to
do that
but ownership in the nba is soft like
the ownership they don't want to be
in uncomfortable situations they don't
want to be seen as anti-player in case
it comes back to bite them down the line
they just don't have the
the stomach
for getting into
that kind of public fight
with one of their players i had someone
suggest to me like
wondering why
nba teams
don't look at the success the green bay
packers had i mean look aaron rodgers
demanded a trade the packers said go fly
a kite
he worked out for rogers individually
the packers went 13-4 and now he's under
new contract with them for the long term
i just think it comes down to
will owners support a front office for
telling a player to take a hike and
right now there aren't more than a
handful of nba owners that have the
stomach to do that why does kevin durant
want out
it's a good question i don't think
there's a clear answer
at this point um
he's obviously been frustrated by
everything that went on in brooklyn last
year you know from the beginning with
kyrie
tau a james harden situation that he
thought was going to work out didn't
work out uh the end of the season
getting swept by boston i i don't know
specifically if there's one thing that
pushed him over that line but that's
where he is and where he still is right
now in terms of of wanting a trade
i just
again it comes down to is will brooklyn
draw the line say we're going to get
this back we're going to get dollar for
dollar value back or else you're going
to be in uniform next year i i don't
know if sean marx and josiah are willing
to do that but again there are a lot of
executives that want them to do that
they want to stop this trend that is
beginning to grow in the nba
any other suitors for kyrie other than
the lakers
no i i talked to someone
in dallas recently and it doesn't seem
like the mavericks are
eager to get into that mix um you know
they're they're still on the lookout for
more help to put around luca doncic but
i i don't get the sense dallas is is
heavily involved uh the lakers seem to
be it
honestly like there's and the lakers
i think right now
they know they're it and that's why
they're not
being overly aggressive in
giving up a first-round draft pick or
taking on a bad contract that makes them
absorb more salary than the nets will so
they're they're kind of in
a wait and see mode but
you know you saw what happened over the
weekend dan where russell westbrook
shows up at a summer league game lebron
james at the same summer league game and
they don't interact
it makes you wonder like no matter how
many things darving ham is saying
dartmouth ham is like the
what's the meme with the guys on
everything's on fire and he's like all
is well like darvanham's like i can't
wait to get russell westbrook back in
the training camp
darwin's a great guy and i'm sure deep
down he or on some level he believes it
but deep down he's got to know
that's probably going to be untenable so
if we get into like august that's where
i think all this is going to go remember
when kyrie demanded a trade from
cleveland he didn't get traded to late
august so i think we're i think this is
going to drag out you know during the
summer um and when we get to late august
maybe early september do the nets say
you know what
maybe brooklyn isn't lying maybe they
will bring him back maybe there is
somebody else out there and we'll give
you that 2027 first we'll take joe
harris's contract back just to make sure
we don't have to go into this uh season
with uh with russell westbrook on the
roster is chris mannix sports
illustrated senior writer you were at
the summer league uh last night chad
holmgren thought we were going to have
the showdown with paulo bancaro but
they've shut him down
what do you make of i know guys have
been great in summer leagues before
uh i fell in love with josh hart in the
summer league a few years ago
what are you seeing from homegrown that
will translate into success during the
regular season ah the list of summer
league stars is long and terrible that's
uh nate robinson i believe still has his
jersey retired at the uh vegas summer
league um
the skills are obvious i mean he might
be the highest upside player in this
draft he's a seven footer that can
collect the ball off the glass and start
a fast break the number of centers
in today's nba that can do that it's
it's one it's nicole yogic he's
basically it so if check can play the
position and rebound and dribble like
that
he's gonna be a real weapon offensively
the three-point shot is obviously there
the playmaking
everything is obviously there he's the
skinniest player i've ever seen i mean
skinnier
yeah
yeah i mean comparable at least i mean i
haven't
the comparisons i was making in modern
nba i guess okay have been durant as a
rookie and giannis as a rookie
they're bodybuilders compared to him as
a rookie i mean he is just
i don't know how to describe him how
skinny he is in every facet of his body
and that's a concern you know i wrote
about this last week like he got a lot
of praise for that first summerly game
for knocking down four threes and
playing off the dribble why one coach
sitting courtside it was like yeah look
he showed skills but the reason he was
shooting jump shots is because he didn't
have the strength to get around guys and
that's going to continue to be a problem
during his rookie year he's gonna have
to make tough shots to score in the nba
right now and
i i don't know how strong he's going to
get he's certainly going to add strength
but dan as recently as a couple of weeks
ago he was 195 i mean he's seven foot
195 pounds like if he was a boxer he
wouldn't even be a heavyweight like
that's how skinny uh he is so i don't
know
how much weight he's gonna put on that
frame how much strength that's gonna add
what position he's going to slide into
at nba level because i watched in that
his best game again was that opener
against utah in the salt lake summer
league and i watched guys like uh kofi
cockburn and i watched taco fall
physically control him and i watch in
the second game you know kenny lofton
juniors drive into his chest and make
plays these are summer league players
and you get into the nba and nba players
are gonna do the same thing and then
some so i think he's gonna have some
great moments as a rookie he's got some
really tough moments as a rookie and i
think three years down the line we're
going to figure out if he was worth that
number too big and i think he ended up
with the right organization i think
oklahoma city is wonderful wonderful at
developing young talent um the in season
tournament that the commissioner is
talking about do we do we have any
further details on this
no this is i mean if
if adam silver was captain ahab this is
his moby dick like having
getting this in-season tournament over
the line is
all adam silver's been focused on in
nba
in-season changes or season change for
the last few years um there's not
an overwhelming amount of interest
amongst owners to do it in part because
you've got to negotiate with the players
for it you've got to give them
like each player from the winning team
would get a million dollars is one
variation of of this that i've seen uh
you'd probably have to reduce the
schedule from 82 to 78 games which
doesn't seem like a lot but affects
revenue you know gate revenue tv revenue
all the above and owners don't really
have the appetite to do that as well
this is going to be tough for silver to
push over the finish line it's certainly
possible but
um
you know to me that
where the owner's interest is we can get
into this the owner's interest is in the
play-in tournament and not really in the
in-season tournament before i let you go
i did wonder about this if kyrie is gone
and kd goes
is steve nash a lame duck coach in
brooklyn
yeah i don't know what steve's appetite
is for coaching a rebuilding team now to
be fair the nets are never going to be
trying to rebuild largely because they
have no control of their own draft picks
right like they lose
they celebrate houston for that because
of the james harden deal so the nets and
this goes back to what they're asking
for in negotiations they're far more
focused right now on getting players
back than they are draft picks back the
rudy gobert trade was nice and the jazz
got exactly what they're looking for but
the jazz are trending towards a full
rebuild the nets want to remain
competitive at some level that's why
they're looking at deandre ayton and
mikhail bridges that white that's why
jaylen brown
might make some sense so
they're they're going to be competitive
one way or the other um but does steve
nash want to coach a
middle of the pack type playoff team the
nets want him to coach that type of team
look steve nash
he got clobbered last year dan he did
like he was you know imeodoka coached
circles around him in in the playoffs
and
steve's not the only problem it wasn't
the only problem with that team but he
certainly didn't look like the solution
you know in the postseason last year so
when the dust settles on all this that
that's probably going to be a
conversation the nets have depending on
what kind of team they have going into
training camp thank you chris as always
we appreciate your time and uh safe
travels
ricky rubio he's back big season let's
go yes absolutely
i'm moving moving to indiana or
cleveland wherever he is you don't even
know where he
a lot of jerseys damn a lot of jerseys
yeah i know i know that's chris mannix
sports illustrated senior writer and the
president of the ricky rubio fan club
not a lot of members in there but he is
the president